in the run-up to World War 2 France
spent almost a decade building the
famous Majin o-line 450 miles of
concrete bunkers and weapon
installations protected the country from
an impending invasion and it was
heralded as a work of military genius
because if everything went in Frances
favor the plan was simple hold off
German forces long enough to mobilize a
massive counter-attack but of course
things did not go in Frances favor
Germany got past this modern great wall
the simplest way in knew how by walking
around it based on Germany's strategy
during World War one French officials
assumed the attackers would avoid the
rough terrain of the Ardennes Forest but
Germany revised its battle plans
sweeping through the weak point in the
art den rendering the southern defences
useless the Majah no line has since
become a parable for grandiose efforts
that offered no real security I'm
reminded of the marginal line every time
I play they are billions developed by
Spanish studio new montien games and
released in early access two months ago
this RTS punishes anyone who refuses to
adapt if you don't learn from your
mistakes you'll likely die they are
billion seems initially simple but it
hides a multitude of layers
it takes place in a procedurally
generated steampunk post-apocalypse you
have to build a new colony expand it and
defend it from increasingly large waves
of zombies this may sound like a
combination of tired tropes but it's
actually remarkable how well they all
come together it's one of those rare
games where every detail is essential to
its personality and design the
procedural generation for instance
forces you into a survivors mindset in
one match you can force the zombies into
a choke point between the cliffs and a
nearby lake in the next you have to
expand your colony much sooner to take
advantage of an iron deposit for your
snipers weapons the unpredictable
placement of forests coastlines and
zombie villages forces you not to master
specific Maps but the actual rules of
the wasteland it's not about memorizing
the same terrain over and over again
it's about learning resource management
and troop placement so you can make the
best of each random landscape as for the
steampunk trappings these two play a
pivotal role in the mechanics of the
game yes the cel-shaded valves and steam
whistles are vibrant and gorgeous but
they also solve the perennial challenge
of RTS base construction some games
solve this with limited build plots
others expand outward from something
like a Construction Yard
they are billions however lets you snake
your base around lakes through canyons
and into the far corners of each map you
accomplish this with Tesla coils build
one and it provides energy to nearby
farms turrets and other Tesla coils by
the late game stages you'll likely have
dozens of these towers strung throughout
the landscape powering your
post-apocalyptic colony in its own
clever way they are billions let's it's
setting drive its gameplay and of course
this also rings true for the game's
undead horde we've seen zombies and
dozens if not hundreds of games over the
past 25 years they've shambled through
every genre on every platform we've
owned and as the zombie trope
oversaturated games as well as TV and
film it became an ironic commentary on
itself a lifeless husk limping forward
with no end in sight but the zombie
stories that stuck with us were the ones
that understood why zombies could be
compelling to begin with Resident Evil
used them to constantly morph your
expectations of Spencer mansion
left4dead which actually turns ten this
year use them to create cooperative
survival scenarios Shaun of the Dead
satirized the simultaneous terror and
ridiculousness of the undead masses they
are billions joins the pantheon of
memorable zombie tales in fact to point
to a recent entry in the genre they are
billions does World War Z better than
World War Z in new mantheon games RTS
zombies swarm your defenses in tidal
waves coming from random directions
pouring through choke points and
overwhelming your carefully prepared
defenses on its website new man team
claims that can have 20,000 zombies on
screen at one time and after 40 hours
with this game I can confirm that's true
with this kind of scale they are
billions shows just how helpless your
colony can be of course zombies aren't
just scary because of their numbers but
also how they multiply here to new
mantheon uses clever systems to heighten
the tension in almost every other RTS
one basic grunt unit won't usually lead
to game over and they are billions
however that one basic zombie can infect
a small building spawn a few more
friends infect two more buildings and so
on until a horde has formed behind your
walls in a matter of seconds these
massive swarms of enemies are all the
more terrifying when you realize just
how dangerous each individual unit can
be all of this adds up to a game with an
extremely strong identity it's a
steampunk post-apocalypse zombie RTS and
all of these components are essential in
creating an exhilarating experience it's
a deep strategy game it's a terrifying
zombie entry it uses procedural
generation to its advantage and even now
I can't wait to play more because not
only is they are billions thrilling but
it's one of the best realtime strategy
games to release in the last decade this
is high praise contrary to recent
refrain the genre has not been dying and
it certainly is not dead
this sentiment ignores games such as
total war Warhammer to homeworld deserts
of carrot or the exceptional off world
trading company whether through
large-scale battles or economic
management these titles offer fresh
takes on the arty
legacy and what a legacy that is some of
the best PC games have sprung from this
lineage we have franchises such as
command & Conquer Age of Empires and
total war
not to mention licensed games such as
Star Wars Empire at war or battle for
middle-earth and its sequel and of
course we have Warcraft orcs and humans
the game that would spark a franchise
and become the breakthrough hit for one
of today's juggernaut developers it was
Warcraft competition with command &
Conquer that sparked the RTS boom of the
late 90s while Westwood Studios series
emphasized military action blizzard
pursued story and characterization this
rivalry gave birth to Starcraft in 1998
another Blizzard project that proves
successful bringing the studio's refined
RTS formula to a sci-fi setting but it
was Starcraft 2 in 2010 that truly
refined that formula it took everything
that made its predecessor excellent
except local land capabilities and
amplified it even more its factions have
distinct identities and play styles it
tells an engaging story with memorable
characters and like many Blizzard games
its systems are easy enough to learn but
very difficult to master it's one of the
best realtime strategy games because the
individual parts of its identity are all
essential to its overall design they are
billions continues that innovative
legacy and as of now 500,000 people have
tried it it may only be in early access
but it is one of the best realtime
strategy games in years and one of the
best zombie games to date if you've been
craving an intelligent RTS that reveals
new depths each time you play they are
billions as your game if you've been
craving a great zombie game in a
landscape where they are oversaturated
they are billions deserve your time
however before we go I do have one piece
of advice always remember the majah no
line
[Music]